دبي هو عبد الخالق عبد الله أستاذ
العلوم السياسية في جامعة الإمارات العربية المتحدة، من
الجيد أن تكون
معك وأنا أتحدث بانتظام أريد
أن أبدأ بعزف القليل من
الرئيس بايدن وهو يتحدث من تل أبيب
أمس سيدي،
استمع، يجب أن تكون العدالة  تم ذلك ولكني
أحذر من ذلك بينما تشعر
أن الغضب لا يستهلكه بعد
11 سبتمبر، كنا غاضبين في الولايات المتحدة
بينما سعينا لتحقيق العدالة وحصلنا على العدالة،
كما ارتكبنا
أخطاء أقرب إلى الدعوة
لضبط النفس دون استخدام فعلي
كلمة يجب أن أقولها لا توجد دعوات لخفض
التصعيد أو تهدئة
الوضع ونعلم أنه
لم يتم الاتفاق على وقف إطلاق النار أثناء وجود
الرئيس الأمريكي هنا كان من
الصعب جدًا تحديد
أهدافه في هذه الرحلة ماذا  لقد
حققوا بالطبع فتح
معبر رفح الحدودي لعبور حوالي 20
شاحنة وهو أمر
مهم بالطبع بالنظر إلى ما أه
الوضع الكارثي القريب من الكارثي
هناك لكني فقط أتساءل هل تقيمون
كيف ستقيمون تأثير
رحلة الرئيس الأمريكي إلى إسرائيل في ضوء
القلق الحقيقي الآن بشأن الشكل الذي
ستبدو عليه المرحلة التالية من هذه الحرب على حماس، شكرًا
لاستضافتي
بيكي أعتقد أه الرئيس لم
يبدو ولو بترة كصانع
سلام، الخطاب الذي ألقاه هو
شهادة
اليوم أه ظهر كصانع
حرب أه كمروج للحرب لقد
انحاز تمامًا
لإسرائيل وأعتقد أنه
يجر أمريكا إلى هذا فهو يجعل
هذه ليست حرب نتنياهو بل
حرب بايدن إنه يجعل هذه ليست حربًا  حرب إسرائيلية
بل حرب أمريكية ولهذا السبب
أه أنت تعلم أنهم ألغوا القمة ولهذا
السبب أمريكا فقط تعطي
الضوء الأخضر الدعم السياسي المعنوي الكامل
مهما كان الدعم الذي
يمكن أن تقدمه أمريكا لإسرائيل لمواصلة
هذه الإبادة الجماعية في غزة
هذا موقف شخصي أو
تشعر حقًا أن هذه هي الطريقة التي
سارت بها تلك الرحلة عبر
المنطقة إذا نظرت إلى المنطقة إذا
رأيت للتو أه مقطع الفيديو الخاص بك أه
الناس غاضبون بشدة 4 ملايين عربي
اليوم أكثر  غاضبون أكثر من أي وقت مضى
خلال هذه
المظاهرة التي رأيناها للتو في أمان
في القاهرة وراباخ وفي كل
مكان وأعتقد أن هناك غضبًا ومعظم
هذا الغضب موجه بالطبع ضد
إسرائيل ولكن معظمه أيضًا كثير  منه
أيضًا موجه اليوم ضد أمريكا معاداة
أمريكا في أعلى مستوياتها على الإطلاق
هنا وأعتقد أن أمريكا
تجرنا بهذا الدعم الكامل الكامل
للحرب الإسرائيلية وأعتقد أنها
تجر الشرق الأوسط بأكمله إلى
دورة جديدة من صراع التصعيد و
اضطراب هذه أخبار سيئة لأمريكا
لا أعتقد أن هذا رأيي الشخصي
ولكنه رأي الجميع
نعم هذه بالتأكيد دعوات
الإدانة أه نسمع في جميع أنحاء
المنطقة دعوات التهدئة
لوقف هذا العمل العسكري مع
تزايد الدعوات  الحالة الأولى
لوقف إطلاق النار، هذا ما أخبرني به وزير الخارجية الأردني
بالأمس. التصور المتزايد في
الشارع عندما يرون هذه السحابة الحديدية التي لا لبس فيها
تدعم إسرائيل في
هذه الحرب، إنه تصور متزايد بأن
هذه حرب عربية إسلامية غربية.
المكان الذي لا نريد الوصول إليه، هذا هو
المكان الذي يجب علينا جميعًا أن نعمل على
منع الدخول إليه، ولهذا السبب
يجب أن تصمت الأسلحة، يجب أن يعود الفطرة السليمة، ويجب أن
تعود العقلانية ونكتشف طريقة للخروج  في
هذا الظلام، فإن خطر توسع هذه الحرب
إلى الضفة الغربية إلى
أجزاء أخرى من المنطقة أمر حقيقي، وعلينا
أن نوقف ذلك قبل فوات الأوان لنا
جميعا أن
نردد كلماتك هناك.
تحدث معي عبد الخالق عن موقف دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  على
وجه التحديد، الإمارات العربية المتحدة هي أو على الأقل
أنت تعرف أهم حليف
إقليمي لإسرائيل ما هو الدور، إن وجد، الذي
يقال إن الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية السعودية على سبيل المثال قريبتان من تطبيع العلاقات
قبل بدء هذا الصراع ما هو الدور
أه الذي تلعبه هاتان الدولتان في
تهدئة الأمور في  هذه النقطة
أعتقد أن الإمارات مثل السعودية
مثل كل الآخرين
ينسقون كثيرا مع القاهرة مهم جدا
العاصمة هناك يسيطرون كثيرا أه
ينسقون جهودهم
وسياساتهم مع الأردن الأردن
هناك لذلك هناك موقف عربي مشترك أه
لم يسبق لي أن رأيت
حكومات عربية متحدة اليوم كما هي الآن
عندما يتعلق الأمر بهذه الإبادة الجماعية ضد
غزة، لذا فإن التحالف العالمي جزء من العالم العربي، لقد
عقدنا بالأمس اجتماعًا لمجلس التعاون الخليجي حيث
كانت الإمارات العربية المتحدة حاضرة هناك.  جاء مجلس التعاون الخليجي
بأقوى إدانة يمكن أن
تسمعها على الإطلاق لإسرائيل على الرغم من أن UA و
bahin لديهما علاقة طبيعية طبيعية
مع إسرائيل، وهذا
أبعد من هذا تمامًا هنا موناس يُدعى
إسرائيل يطلق العنان
لألعابه النارية وقواته غير المنضبطة وأعتقد أن هذا
الدير يحتاج إلى أن يكون  مسيطر عليها
ولا أحد يستطيع السيطرة عليها أكثر من أمريكا
وأمريكا لا تقوم
بعملها هل ترى نهاية
تطبيع العلاقات أم مع
الدول العربية في هذه
المرحلة لا أعتقد أنك تعلم أن مصر قامت
بتطبيع العلاقات
مع إسرائيل وقد قامت بذلك  لقد مررت
بالعديد من هذه الحلقات، وكذلك فعلت الآن
الإمارات العربية المتحدة، وأعتقد أن هذا
سيضع حدًا لكنه لن
يعكس العملية، فهناك
عملية موجودة وقرار استراتيجي
ولها منطقها الخاص، لذلك أنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا
أرى عكس
التطبيع مع إسرائيل لكني أرى أن
الساق السياسية مهتزة وأعتقد أنها
متذبذبة وعلى إسرائيل أن تفعل شيئا
لتقويتها ولكن أه إذا
استمر ذلك ربما لا أستبعد
أن إسرائيل
أه سفير هنا  يتم طرده وقد
يحدث نفس الشيء في مصر
والأردن وكل هذه الدول العربية الناس
غاضبون جدًا من الحكومة والناس
في جميع أنحاء الشرق الأوسط وهذا
يعيدنا إلى أه المربع صفر بيكي
كنا نظن أن هذه المنطقة في حالة من
التهدئة ديتون أه محادثة نحن
العودة إلى الصراع سنعود
إلى التوتر وإذا كانت هذه الأمور قد
تخرج عن نطاق السيطرة إذا قررت إيران الانضمام إليها
إذا قررت الانضمام إليها فسيكون الأمر
سيئًا للغاية في الأيام القادمة
عبد الخالق عبده أه شكرًا جزيلا  إن
رؤيتك وتحليلاتك
مهمة للغاية في هذه
المرحلة